in our previous video about piranha
solution we submerged all sorts of
things from skittles to bananas
but today as promised it's our
traditional chicken leg
so
neil tackled the chicken leg
i bought him a whole kilo of chicken
legs but he just tried one
the amazing thing with the chicken leg
in piranha solution is that the reaction
went very much faster than in all the
other acids we've tried previously
braided had to video for a whole 24
hours to get much effect but
this time the effect was much more rapid
initially
neil dangled the chicken leg
into the piranha solution meat that was
submerged dissolved quite quickly again
producing some carbon
because
meat is an organic compound contains
carbon but not as much water
as
vegetable matter
it's getting there
i think it's going of fizz
but gradually neil got a bit more
impatient
so neil
gradually put more and more of the
chicken leg into the acid eventually
cutting the wire so that most of it was
submerged the reaction became quite
violent
more frothing
and
the meat
started falling off the bone something
we'd never seen before with other acids
[Music]
and the bone itself
started to dissolve piranha solution had
behaved almost like a saw
it cut off everything that was submerged
so
through the bone you got a section you
could see the marrow inside
and even the marrow had gone black
presumably because being attacked by the
solution again i don't think there was
quite enough acid
because if there'd been enough
solution
the whole chicken leg would have
disappeared but it was pretty impressive
so i think there's some quite
interesting questions
first of all
why does the piranha solution work and i
think it's
due to this combination of having
sulfuric acid that can dehydrate things
remove the elements of water
and then hydrogen peroxide that is very
strongly oxidizing and it becomes more
oxidizing in strongly acidic conditions
so
the high concentrations of h plus
make it
easier for it to attack things that's
why it can attack carbon professor why
does the
sulfuric acids removal of the water help
the h plus
do such an effective job
i think it does several things first of
all the reaction with the acid heats
everything up
and when you heat up a reaction it goes
faster
secondly it produces this finely divided
carbon
which has a large surface area so it can
be attacked much better than if you had
a solid lamp
and
the h plus
can then have got the peroxide primed so
that it's ready to attack i think it is
a good demonstration of how when you use
a mixture of chemicals you can have a
bigger effect than using either of the
chemicals individually
we've seen this with aqua regia
dissolving gold
where a mixture of nitric acid and
hydrochloric acid will dissolve gold
but the two acids individually
won't it may be that in the piranha
solution
there is a small concentration of
so-called carrots acid
which is peroxy sulfuric acid which
itself is a very strong oxidizing agent
and that might add a bit of extra bump
to the reaction so the final question
which we
discussed with sulfuric acid where
murderers have dissolved bodies
of their victims
in sulfuric acid is why
they didn't use piranha solution
and perhaps some have but then it's not
documented
and i think the reason is first of all
it's quite hard to get hold of large
quantities of hydrogen peroxide
and the other reason is you've seen
from the banana experiment
and others that it can be really messy
and if you're quietly trying to
dispose of your victim the last thing
you want to do is to get them bubbling
all over the floor of the room and you
have such a mess of really corrosive
material that you've got to clear up
you